Показую, як працюється.
Аби був повний рост, треба ставать на коліна і працювать.
А так як? Спина болить, все болить.
Працюється дуже складно, але ми працюєм, слава Богу!
Працівники швидкої допомоги України, розраховуючи на "Божу допомогу",
поспішають на термінові виклики, рятують життя і спонтанно приймають пологи.
Підвищити ефективність роботи "служби 103" вже понад рік намагаються
в межах медичної реформи. Окрім оновлення автопарку швидких
та модернізації диспетчерських, ідеться про цілковиту зміну
підходу до обслуговування громадян, які потребують екстреної допомоги.
Що варто знати, перш ніж викликати "швидку"?
За офіційними даними, 6 мільйонів 900 тисяч викликів
екстреної медичної допомоги на рік. Це надзвичайно велика кількість
для обмежених ресурсів служби. Загалом по Україні бригад "швидкої" - близько трьох тисяч.
За даними МОЗ, дві третини пацієнтів не отримують своєчасно допомоги "швидкої".
Причина - нетермінові виклики, які заважають рятувати пацієнтів
у дійсно скрутному становищі, коли не можна гаяти ані хвилини.
Карети їдуть деінде та не встигають туди, де вкрай потрібні.
Для оптимізації ресурсів МОЗ ухвалив розділити виклики-звернення громадян на 4 категорії.
Категорія перша: якщо хворий у критичному стані,
потребує реанімаційних заходів, негайного реагування або втручання.
Час до першого безпосереднього контакту з хворим
для цієї категорії має становити менше 10 хвилин.
Друга категорія: екстрений виклик,
стан пацієнта "потенційно серйозний" і може потребувати швидкої оцінки,
невідкладної допомоги на місці або невідкладного транспортування.
Швидка має прибути на такий виклик менше ніж за 20 хвилин, вимагає МОЗ.
До третьої категорії відносять несерйозні стани,
коли загрози життю та здоров'ю пацієнта немає,
наприклад, загострення хронічних хвороб.
Такі виклики будуть скеровані на первинну ланку.
За можливості на виклик поїде бригада, яка не задіяна
на викликах для першої та другої категорій.
І зрештою - четверта категорія: непрофільні виклики.
Бригада екстреної допомоги не виїздить,
пацієнт може отримати телефонну консультацію чи буде відправлений до сімейного лікаря.
Тариф на виклик "швидкої" з 1 липня 2020 року підвищено до 163 гривень.
Раніше він становив112 гривень. Відповідні угоди
на надання невідкладної допомоги за новим тарифом
Національна служба здоров'я України вже укладає з медичними установами.
Для самих пацієнтів у фінансовому плані нічого не зміниться.
Виклик державної "швидкої" залишається безкоштовним, на відміну від приватних клінік.
Конкретні підстави для звернення за номером "103" по всій Україні
містяться в наказі МОЗ номер 370. Це, зокрема,
втрата свідомості, судоми, раптовий розлад дихання,
раптовий біль у грудній клітці, усі види травм та тваринних укусів та невідкладна стоматологія.
Чи зміниться цей перелік, у МОЗ наразі не повідомляють.
Підвищена температура чи проблеми з тиском до нього не входять.
Слід відзначити, що хоча нові правила спрощують
фільтрування викликів бригадами "швидкої",
вони і раніше могли не виїздити на звернення громадян,
що тепер відносяться до 3 та 4 категорій.
Приміром, аби забрати породіллю на планові пологи,
дитину для видалення кліщів або літнього хворого для планової госпіталізації.
Утім, неекстрені виїзди, на думку експертів,
будуть траплятися і у майбутньому в тих випадках,
коли, зокрема, пацієнти чи їхні рідні, здійснюючи виклик,
надаватимуть недостовірну інформацію про стан здоров'я.